yeah welcome to this video playing never
mind the gannets a teammate of mine
played them a draw the end the session
okay he's not actually is Sicilian
player so let's see what happens if I go
wow this is dull okay yeah so let's take
him so it's some kind of a Sicilian
French mix and where he really early
stuff like I'm up I'm up a move or
something hmm you know he didn't lose a
temple but it's a very early capture
yeah this is what I'm saying while
trying to say maybe but I'm sorry maybe
Queen takes speeding up development
Jeff so castles yeah at the end I
probably need to lose a move back here
by capturing an approving structure
almost the Queen again so basically
sorry for this a bit of a sore throat
here um so this really didn't work out
with Queen default mmm yeah how to put
the hardware to put the Queen
hmm
yeah this looks really like Cindy
chassis but I'm fling moving the Queen
all the time judges pawn takes then c5
coming later I can play 95 actually
night if 95 is not so bad I hope the
only slight justification for all those
moves and Squibbles really but take a
couple of times oh I'm in opinion silent
during a bad pen ok so let's grub here
and now what now should I take I can I
can't play 92 first or especially age
radio threat the null move is just to
grab it knight c6 I think it's oh wait
as a shot calculators in quincy seven I
thought maybe nighty 7s playable yeah
maybe it is Quincy eight Quincy eight
down really nonsense at the entire take
there anyway I didn't I only thought it
was 92 ok so I know we have a simplified
position where he's got a potentially
good bishop but he's got porn weaknesses
a six and c6 and I have ideas like night
be 3 a 5 and so on attacking this so
here
oh this is too superficial I'm thinking
about maybe you can place you five so
maybe yeah it's probably silver the way
to go it's how to play such a position
without them secure the back ring
maybe Queenie three years I'm overdoing
it a bit it's possible don't run 133
didn't really see that I was so down on
time
mmm ya black ass up I serve in very good
shape you
hmm
annoying you know this is very passive
why did I do that hmm okay yeah it
really feels bad to defense or passively
the only thing is he's got some loose
units here this one of the porn queen c6
mh4 I can take d5
hmm maybe this is still still playable
maybe he certainly am didn't use his
some chances to the fullest pretty sure
about that they charge for him but Sir
not know is nice to defend try to get
the passport here at least the Queen on
d5 is covering g2 this possible meeting
square
yeah he threatened 133 twice the night
is really off side
attacking the rook and tonight be five
yeah Quincy 60 ah what the heck quince
is six ok I'm still attacking the song
and it's good cook age five rook age 50
this is this is the killer don't don't
have any any sort of reply against the
smooth okay okay yeah well at least I'm
know what to play morning check check
check check check
yeah it's a teammate of mine I I really
hope he won't play on time against me
otherwise I need to need to go to only
to threaten with serious consequences
whatever and so I'm gay could have one
here obviously I was really outplayed
okay rook age five unless I'm totally
blind o gauge fibers as Miss winning
season medium yeah Queen edge force the
only only move to avoid instant mate you
know why well it was the time scramble
Queen a eight wins here but this is just
pure coincidental yeah this is the
counter-attack with Queen h8 mate but ok
I didn't really think about that ok
thanks for watching